salut dans la première vidéo on a évoqué
l'argument de l'homme de paille et on a
brièvement rappelé son contraire le
style manne pour introduire un style man
sous stéroïdes la charité en monétique
pour résumer rapidement la charité à
magnétique est une attitude qui consiste
à produire soi-même les conditions de
pertinence de la phrase qu'on vous
exprime ses se poser tout un tas de
questions avant même de choisir une
interprétation pour donner toute sa
chance à la position d'interlocuteur
si on met cette attitude là sous
stéroïdes ça devient ce qu'on pourrait
appeler la charité perspectiviste ça
renvoie à la capacité à se mettre à la
place de l'autre ça peut faire écho à la
question du perspective taking on évoqué
brièvement dans la vidéo sur la place
d'autrui dans notre histoire personnelle
je ne suis pas un spécialiste de cette
notion il faudra l'aborder plus en
détails plus tard ce qu'on dirait pour
le moment c'est que pour simuler
correctement le point de vue d'autrui
il faut être capable d'imaginer le lieu
d'où ils parlent pour le dire autrement
il s'agit de se donner une chance de
comprendre dans quel monde ce qui est
dit est vrai voilà une piste magnifique
dans quel monde ce que dit autrui est il
vrai en un sens on pourrait dire que
c'est chercher à comprendre autrui en
tant qu il est un monde en tant qu il
exprime un monde
cette idée fait écho à ce qui est
développé dans la série de vidéos
intitulées ckoi et rationnelle je vous
encourage vivement à aller voir si vous
n'êtes pas convaincus par ce qui est
proposé ici l'idée je le rappelle c'est
de comprendre que l'individu se confond
avec la représentation qu'il se fait du
monde
je vais essayer de le dire de la manière
la plus synthétique possible sans faire
de trop grandes trahisons toute notre
expérience consciente tout ce que l'on
pense voir sans imagine valorise tout
cela est produit par notre cerveau
notre cerveau a des points communs avec
celui des autres ce qui permet de se
mettre d'accord sur certaines choses
pour autant notre cerveau est aussi le
produit de tout un tas de paramètres
héritage génétique stimulation dans la
petite enfance environnement
géographique historique social culturel
événement traumatisant âge etc
ainsi quatre expériences consciente
n'est pas identique à celle des autres
ce qu'on appelle le monde sait ce que
l'on expérimente comme n'étant pas soit
comme ce qui nous fait face
mais même si l'on expérimente comme
cette réalité indépendante tout ce qu'on
croit à son propos c'est ce que notre
cerveau nous en dit donc comme on n'a
pas tous exactement le même cerveau
notre monde n'est pas exactement le même
monde que celui d'autrui
à vrai dire pour être précis il faudrait
ajouter ceci mon nom n'est pas
exactement le même que celui que j'ai
expérimenté hier en fait notre
expérience consciente évolue à chaque
instant même de manière infime et avec
elle l'image du monde que l'on construit
bien sûr il ya des choses qui ne
changent pas qu'ils restent identiques
comme les mathématiques et la logique
cela permet en quelque sorte de pensée
en dehors de son cerveau et les
mathématiques occupe une place
restreinte par rapport aux choses qui
détermine notre quotidien les émotions
les croyances etc
la plupart du temps les désaccords
tiennent à des différences de perception
ou de sensibilité c'est en cela que je
veux dire qu'autrui exprime un monde sa
perspective sur la réalité est une
réalité en tant qu'elle est le fait d'un
cerveau lui même morceau de la réalité
et sa perspective est un monde avec sa
logique
ces échelles de valeur ses priorités et
ses jeudis cerveau pour aller vite mais
c'est évidemment le corps tout entier
qui est concerné
je veux dire que la conscience est un
produit corporelle et que le corps et de
la matière entendre autrui
ça pourrait être s'ouvrir à son
expérience consciente à ce qu'il appelle
réalité s'ouvrir au monde qu'il exprime
au moment où il parle on pourrait voir
là un indice de puissance mentale la
capacité à imaginer le plus de monde
possible pouvoir comprendre les logiques
qui soutiennent le regard d'autrui ne
pas se contenter de scinder le discours
de nos interlocuteurs de manière binaire
en pièces et non biaisée ni même en
rationnel et l'irrationnel comprendre et
sentir les affecte donc les émotions et
les sentiments qui interviennent dans la
logique d'autrui c'est fondamental
puisque faut-il le rappeler être
rationnel ce n'est pas refuser que les
émotions jouent un rôle dans le jugement
il faut donc engager notre sensibilité
notre capacité à imaginer et à projeter
des expériences affective derrière les
mots employés par autrui essayer de
comprendre quelles expériences se cache
derrière telle croyance ou telle pensée
il ne paraît pas d'un guide imaginer
qu'être petits ou grands forts ou
faibles malade ou en bonne santé
beth est moche ou beau et intelligent
tout ceci implique des expériences du
monde différentes et donc des manières
de voir et concevoir le monde différent
on comprendra s'en plaignent que ce
constat s'applique aussi selon qu'on est
plutôt riche ou plutôt pauvre songeur ou
sa sexualité
si on est blanc ou pas blanc qu'on a du
pouvoir ou non etc
je serais prêt à parier un petit paquet
sur le fait qu'une bonne part des
incompréhensions tiennent à la
difficulté ou carrément au refus
d'imaginer la perspective de l'autre
bien sûr ce refus demande également à
être compris si l'on veut espérer de
renverser il faut aussi tenter de
comprendre celui qui ne peut ou ne veut
pas comprendre sinon c'est l'échec
assuré
spinoza au début de son traité politique
l'expriment ainsi j'ai pris grand soin
de ne pas tourner en dérision les
actions humaines ce n'est pas les
déplorer ni les mots d'hier mais de les
comprendre
en d'autres termes les sentiments par
exemple d'amour de haine de colère dans
vie de glorification personnel de joies
et peines par sympathie enfin tous les
mouvements de la sensibilité n'ont pas
été ici considérés comme des défauts de
la nature humaine
ils en sont des manifestations
caractéristiques tout comme la chaleur
le froid le mauvais temps la foudre sont
des manifestations de nature de
l'atmosphère
c'est ce qu'on résume donc par cette
formule célèbre ne pas se moquer ne pas
pleurer ne pas détester mais comprendre
si on ne se fait pas une idée un peu
fine des enjeux affectifs qui sont
impliqués dans la phrase énoncée par
autrui on est quasi certain de passer à
côté d'un éclairage important pour
comprendre le regard de l'autre j'incite
même si ce que je dis n'est pas très
compliqué simplement parce que ça me
paraît très important
la phrase on ne devrait pas faire x
prend un sens très très très différent
si vous avez l'impression que x renvoi
expérience déplaisante vraiment
désagréable ou carrément traumatique ne
pas prendre en compte ce différentiel
affective dans l'évaluation d'une phrase
c'est vraiment pas rationnel du tout
certains seront peut-être tentés de
répondre c'est impossible de se mettre à
la place de l'autre je crois que c'est
pas une objection très juste d'abord
parce que même si on pense à un possible
eh bien j'ai l'impression que ça devrait
plutôt conduire à plus de précautions et
bienveillance je ne sais pas ce que
l'autre a vécu donc je suspends mon
jugement et j'essaie de comprendre
ensuite parce qu'on a un capital
affectif minimum qui permet de se
projeter
on a tous vécu au moins une fois la
honte le désespoir la solitude la peur
etc
il suffit de se plonger là dedans avec
un peu de bonne volonté enfin parce
qu'il existe beaucoup de ressources
justement pour réussir à mieux simuler
le point de vue d'autrui une petite
fraîcheur internet suffit chercher à
comprendre l'autre ça suppose de
comprendre sa situation et celle ci est
au moins double social et psychologique
bien sûr que les deux sont liés et que
par exemple la situation sociale
détermine la situation psychologique
mais elle ne se recoupent pas
entièrement la lecture sociale est super
efficace pour comprendre des logique
d'ensemble
les rapports de force qui tisse la
société la lecture psychologique doit
prendre le dessus dans les interactions
privé en tête à tête ou entre amis
des facteurs psychologiques comme la
dépression ou l'angoissent peuvent
concerner toutes les classes sociales et
s'avérer parfois bien plus efficace pour
comprendre la position d'un individu
particulier de nous un exemple tout
simple un jeune homme regarde une jeune
fille dans le métro l'erreur du jeune
homme sa limite c'est de ne pas savoir
prendre en compte la perspective de la
jeune fille il ne comprend pas que son
regard peut être lourd menace en usant
parce qu'il s'ajoute à un grand nombre
d'autres regards et qu'il n'est pas très
agréable de se sentir scruter toute la
journée
cela donne un peu le sentiment d'être
une proie c'est relou mais pourquoi tout
cela ne traverse même pas son esprit il
peut y avoir une raison différente bien
sûr ce qui m'intéresse particulièrement
ce vide et que le jeune homme sait
prouve peut-être comme un agneau comme
un enfant comme un être fragile comme la
chose de plus inoffensif du monde
comment lui viendrait-il à l'idée que
son regard soit menaçant alors quoi que
faut-il en conclure
et bien tout simplement qu'autrui n'a
pas accès à ce que vous êtes prendre en
compte la perspective de la jeune fille
cela aurait voulu dire garder à l'esprit
que tout ce à quoi l accès c'est un
énième regard supplémentaires posés sur
elle sans doute son regard at-il
sincèrement doux mais cela ne suffit pas
la jeune fille ne le connaît pas lui
donc tout ce qu'elle voit
c'est ce regard insistant est ce à dire
que la jeune fille devrait faire
l'effort d'intégrer la perspective du
jeune homme d'imaginer qu'il se vit
peut-être comme un être inoffensif et le
contraire d'un prédateur oui et non oui
au sens où s'il en est capable
tant mieux cela lui rendra sûrement
l'expérience des regards à moins
désagréable plus on a de compassion a
priori pour autrui - ces actions nous
dérange mais non car c'est là une
interaction entre des inconnus aussi la
grille sociologique redevient pertinente
on peut pas attendre de quelqu'un qui
subit des regards voir des remarques
toute la journée que cette personne
fasse un effort supplémentaire pour
apprendre à gérer cela au cas par cas si
on a regardé toute la journée on peut
pas donner toute sa chance à chaque
regain garder ça en tête ça permet de
mieux décoder les enjeux de situation la
perspective sociale nous aident à
clarifier le rôle de chacun dans les
interactions dans la sphère privée
nos limites sont présentes également
mais si l'on fait l'effort d'établir une
relation de confiance il est possible de
surmonter en partie certaines
difficultés qui empêchent habituellement
de se mettre à la place de l'autre pour
mieux vivre une discussion il est
parfois éclairant de garder à l'esprit
que la plupart des êtres humains
s'éprouve comme fragiles ont des
angoisses défendent des croyances avant
tout parce qu elle les rassure etc
je me souviens avoir dit en classe une
fois partait du principe que ce qu'on
vous dit est vrai pris hors contexte
ressemble et le pire conseils possibles
quelqu'un qui loue l'attitude sceptique
mais il ne s'agit évidemment pas
d'adopter définitivement une croyance il
s'agit de se donner une chance
d'entendre ce qui est dit c'est
d'ailleurs une position qu'on adapte en
anthropologie
si au cours de ses discussions avec les
autochtones l'anthropologue est
confrontée à des éléments de langage qui
lui apparaissent de son point de vue
illogique coûts afférents
il doit partir du principe que ce qu'on
lui dit et bien logique mais souvent une
certaine configuration de sens qui lui
échappe
ça vaut pour nous aussi même si les
différences sont moins directement
visibles je disais entendre ça veut dire
percevoir les implications
on n'entend rien si on rejette
immédiatement si on ne fait pas l'effort
de projeter le monde
associé à la phrase or la puissance de
notre monde tient peut-être à sa
capacité à se transformer à devenir des
mondes différents
en ce sens partir du principe que c'est
vrai cela revient à se demander qu'est
ce que ça veut dire si c'est vrai qu'est
ce qui change de l'idée qu'on se fait du
monde si c'est vrai quel est le
comportement qu'il faut adopter si c'est
vrai ce qui veut dire aussi penser le
vrai en termes graduelles et non de
manière binaire
certes il y à des raisonnements valides
et non valides
certes il y à des descriptions plus ou
moins fidèle de la réalité mais ça ne
recoupe qu'une partie du problème
nous faisons l'expérience de l'existence
celle ci est composée de perception de
sentiments de valeur de désir et cette
chose sont très importantes
elle joue un rôle central dans notre
quotidien quand on ne se concentre que
sur la validité logique des phrase
énoncée par notre interlocuteur
on met de côté ce qu'elles contiennent
l'information relative à ces perceptions
sentiment désir et c'est tendre une
oreille à logique c'est à dire qu'ils
seraient ni logique ni logique ou en
dehors de la question logique ou
rationnel ce serait se donner une chance
de découvrir la sensibilité de notre
interlocuteur
quand une personne parle elle exprime sa
sensibilité et celle ci exprime à son
tour le monde de la personne se
comprendre se respecter c'est aussi
faire l'effort d'entendre la réalité
sensible exprimé dans le point de vue
d'autrui les désirs les affecte les
valeurs en jeu dans son existence
il n'est pas si clair que la validité
belgique puisse suffire à rendre
légitime notre désir de convaincre
autrui à lui faire voir les choses
telles qu'on les voit c'est ce qu'on
évoque brièvement dans une vidéo bleus
sur les raisonnements ce n'est pas parce
que notre regard sur le monde et
démontrable donc nous apparaît comme
fiables
que cela nous donne le droit de
l'imposer aux autres la rationalité et
la logique sont des outils pas une
finalité qui devrait l'emporter surtout
certains de ces chevaliers blancs de
l'esprit critique qui veulent imposer un
mode 100% rationnelle sont sûrement
animés de bonnes intentions
c'est qu'il est très difficile de
prendre du recul vis-à-vis de la logique
elle-même il ne s'agit pas de pointer
les limites du raisonnement logique au
sens ou un autre type de raisonnement
pourrait faire mieux
il s'agit de dire que ce n'est pas le
seul critère par exemple beaucoup se
demandent comment convaincre quelqu'un
ou comment faire prendre conscience à
quelqu'un que sa croyance est
irrationnel c'est tout de même un sacré
point de départ même si cette
bienveillance et partir du principe
qu'il vaut mieux pour l'autre qu'ils
adoptent notre façon de voir les choses
en général comme on ne se voit pas comme
un tyran on trouve une bonne raison de
penser qu'il est bon pour autrui de voir
les choses comme nous la plus fréquente
c'est que ce qu'on dit est plus proche
de la vérité mais ça soulève un paquet
de problèmes et de questions autour de
la vérité et si on ne se met pas
d'accord sur ce qu'on vise dans la
discussion sur ce qu'on appelle vérité
et la place pour lui donne dans notre
échange sur les enjeux éthiques de la
conversation il ya peu de chances que
l'interaction soit très fertile si on
n'a pas le courage de mettre tout ça à
plat pourquoi ne pas alors simplement se
demander ce que son point de vue peut
nous apprendre
par ailleurs on disait nous faisons
l'expérience de l'existence et celle ci
est plus ou moins plaisante
nous cherchons tous à la rendre plus
agréable
cela nous conduit à défendre certaines
choses et en attaque et d'autres nous
défendons ce qui va dans le sens du
monde que nous désirons et nous
attaquerons ce qui menace ce monde sait
que nous sommes pris dans notre
perspective cette somme de croyances et
de désir tisser ensemble et nous sommes
mus par le désir d'une expérience plus
favorable de la réalité même le plus
robotique des esthéticiens il promeut
l'attitude sceptique parce qu'ils
pensent que c'est bon pour le monde que
les choses iraient mieux si les gens
étaient davantage rationnelle etc et si
par hasard ils montrent une chaîne
youtube à leurs ennemis publiquement
pour ce qu'il identifie comme bon il
promeut sa perspective sur le monde donc
et s'il dit je ne fais canaliser je ne
peux pas juger c'est qu'il considère
mieux d'être dans l'analyse de ne pas
s'engager
le désengagement est un engagement et
même l'amour de la vérité est concerné
nous souhaitons mieux connaître le monde
pour améliorer notre existence soit
parce que nous croyons la recherche
scientifique et la quête de
connaissances bonne pour le monde soit
parce que nous visons notre propre
plaisir personnel
nous avons tous des croyances plus ou
moins spontanées ont réfléchi sur ce qui
est plutôt bon plutôt mauvais ces
croyances et esquisse en creux notre
système de valeurs
ce système de valeurs est déterminant
pour notre comportement
il faut faire l'effort de l'interroger
c'est pour ça qu'il faut reconnaître
l'importance des pensées qui se risquent
explicitement au delà du descriptif
qu'il faut donner une chance aux pensées
qui osent proposer et dire voilà comment
il faudrait voir les choses ce sont les
pensées qui rendre explicite d'un
respectives on ne peut pas se contenter
d'anti fier des croyances irrationnelles
on ne peut pas se satisfaire de pointé
du doigt celui ou celle qui argumentent
mal il de déconstruire les complotisme
les plus farfelues de temps que notre
manière de doter et d'interroger les
croyances est nécessairement elle aussi
biaisés si l'étude de la rationalité en
est infaillible
ça serait et puis on fatigue ça demande
beaucoup d'efforts d'être constamment en
train de douter un coup de mou et hop
nos préjugés nos préférences ne valeurs
viennent orienter notre doute c'est
normal nous avons tous des inclinations
et personne n'est capable de les
suspendre complètement celui qui doute
sans garder ça à l'esprit prend le
risque d'adopter un scepticisme orienter
un scepticisme biaisé par sa propre
perspective sur ce qui est bon ou
mauvais pour le monde ce qui est deux
fois plus dangereux parce qu'on se
rassure en se disant qu'on est sceptique
la zététique en ce sens est menacé par
le fantasme de la pure neutralité on
fait comme si dans une discussion on
défend des rien on faisait que viser la
vérité alors on se dédouane au moi je ne
fais que traquer les erreurs aussi
rationnel et les affirmations grand car
il ya un vrai danger à se laisser
prendre au fantasme de l'esprit critique
neutre qui ne ferait qu'une pure analyse
des arguments instinct possible aucun
esprit naissant désir ou sans intérêt de
sa masse qu aux autres et à soi même ce
que l'on défend on se croit immobile
regarder intéressé qu'il ferait que
pointer les erreurs dans les discours
d'autrui alors qu'en fait on s'est
engagé dans une voie pour laquelle on
milite sans même se rendre compte tout
fiers de notre prétendue neutralité à
tous les étés titien ou passionnés de
l'esprit critique
attention à cet orgueil à ce plaisir à
cette bonne conscience qui naît de ce
travail sur la rationalité attention à
cette petite condescendance qui
accompagne la tipp sceptiques il faut
traquer la petite voix en nous qu'ils
balancent les gens croient vraiment
n'importe quoi
c'est un piège c'est dangereux pour soi
et pour les autres
sans compter que c'est un mirage quand
on voit quelqu'un qui se revendique
d'une attitude sceptique pure qui
pensent défendre une position neutre qui
ne ferait que déconstruire des croyances
irrationnelles
on a aussi envie de se dire les gens
croient vraiment n'importe quoi
si l'on cherche simplement à détruire
toute forme de bié on va se retrouver à
se croire non biaisée alors qu'on le
sera toujours plus charitable serait
l'attitude qui consiste à reconnaître
levier ou la perspective la questionner
vérifier si l'on veut effectivement la
défendre c'est à dire mettre à l'épreuve
sa logique sa cohérence
sa compatibilité avec celle des autres
la meilleure manière de lutter contre
des billets ce n'est pas de vouloir les
éradiquer mais de les mettre au jour
c'est pour ça que je crois qu'il faut
rendre aussi explicite que possible
système de valeurs que l'on défend
puisque on défend un système de valeurs
qu'on le veuille ou non c'est donner à
l'autre une chance de comprendre le
monde que l'on promeut lui donner une
chance de l'accepter ou de la refuser en
connaissance de cause et en même temps
je crois qu'il faut savoir entendre le
monde projetée par la tasse natif
d'autrui par monde j'entends ici
l'ensemble de ses croyances ou ce qu'est
la réalité et sur ce qui leur est mieux
qu'elle soit bien sûr qu'il est
important pour juger une pensée de
percevoir sa structure sa rigueur et sa
précision mais ça ne suffit pas il faut
aussi imaginer le monde qui la rend
possible et le monde qu'elle rend
possible donc les perspectives qui lui
sont attachées par là j'entends ce qu'il
faut croire et désiré pour voir les
choses ainsi
est ce que cette vision des choses
invite à croire et désiré on pourrait
imaginer que ces deux choses sont
identiques mais ce n'est pas le cas pour
qu'elles soient identiques il faudrait
que notre vision du monde soit statique
or elles bougent les croyances et désire
évolue plus ou moins imperceptiblement
quittait ce que ce soit dans le même
sens se mettre à désirer plus
intensément une chose ou confirmer une
croyance cela fait bouger notre monde on
gagnerait à pouvoir basculer avec
fluidité de l'analyse des arguments à
l'analyse des perspectives l'analyse
d'une perspective revient à en évaluer
les intérêts en fonction des situations
mais ça demande un gros effort encore
sortir de la logique binaire pour
adopter la pensée en spectres c'est
aussi sans en conclusion faisons un
petit effort d'imagination sémantique
pour donner à la phrase d'autrui toute
sa chance
reconnaissons que nous sommes tous pris
dans une perspective qui implique un
système de valeurs tentons de rendre
explicite la conception du monde que
l'on défend essayons de percevoir dans
la parole de l'autre le monde que lui
défend et confronteront ses projections
avec bienveillance
voilà un beau programme à bientôt